[Musique]
salut baxter vois tu je suis à l'hôpital
on m'a tiré dans la tête quoi on tape
irait dans la tête alors ce patate a
failli me tuer il papa et maman ont
décidé de venir me chercher refuse de
partir avec eux vient à leur tête master
j'y suis jamais arrivé
des enfants tu as deux villes oreilles
de tous on a voulu se mettre au diapason
calais beckham dit fang sont connus pour
leurs improvisations dans des lieux
publics
il s'associe leurs enfants à ces travaux
de création aux parents ils sont
célèbres dans certains milieux six
pièces de la roue est un gars qu'une
réflexion ou une mystification
c'est nous on dirait du sirop d'érable
toujours mais c'est quoi ce bordel
vous n'avez jamais pensé à retravailler
avec vauban je ne suis plus une enfant
et
[Musique]
au feng de nouveau réunis comme il se
devait le musée d'art contemporain de
denver m'a commandé une nouvelle
création
je pense pas que ce soit une bonne idée
c'est pas une bonne idée non vous
trouvez quand vous a fait du mal
si vous avez des enfants vous leur
ferait du mal c'est le sort de tous les
parents et alors on n'a pas besoin de
vous
[Musique]
bonsoir c'est le shérif cheval nous
sommes en présence de faits graves
le véhicule enregistré au nom de vos
parents a été retrouvée sur une aire de
repos nous on a relevé des traces de
lutte ainsi que du sang il s'agit d'une
performance vous pensez qu'il sent
marque
nous envisageons l'hypothèse d'un acte
criminel parents doivent tranquillement
se planquer en se foutant pire notre
gueule et vous n'aurez qu'à les déclarer
mort on le voit ressuscité comme par
miracle
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu fais on va
découvrir où il se cache et jusqu'à ce
qu'on les retrouve on les lâchera pas
[Musique]
c'était une très mauvaise idée de
mélanger famille et amis mais tout ça
c'est de l'histoire ancienne
[Musique]
si on ne peut pas les changer alors
c'est à nous de nous adapter tu crois
que oui je crois qu'on peine
[Musique]
vous pensez qu'ils sont morts je crois
que c'est tout à fait un nom j'ai
possible